[Music]
no Phil look I'm just saying that I had
a dream where you were in this bizarre
kinky Club where everyone just up like
cartoon characters and made out with
each other wait what why are you getting
so defensive about this Oh Phil that is
weird
[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday November
29th I wanted to make you sexy fill fans
comfortable and for those of you who've
never been here before
the nerdfighters and secret siblings in
my pants have teamed up to decrease
worldsuck
using a scavenger hunt pretty jokes yeah
we have terminology I'm sorry about that
anyway Thank You Phil we have like 1500
new subscribers just because you
mentioned us you're a powerful man
philip defranco but we weren't the only
ones who had a big day yesterday secret
sister Melissa Jenna got on an airplane
and flew to st. Petersburg Florida to
participate in the CNN YouTube debates
that participate there at the end was
given me some problems hope you're
having a good time Melissa Jon yesterday
I realized that because of Thanksgiving
I'm not doing a song until next week and
because of that I only have two more
songs to do which is really amazing
because I have already written oh my god
it's such a load off the songwriting
actually fun and sometimes people like
the songs which is really really awesome
but it's hard it takes a lot of time and
I don't have a lot of time especially
because I've decided to give all of that
time away to people who care about me
and love me so if one of those people
wants me to write a song for them
that'll be fantastic especially if the
song is about one Christmas or two
eating your wife god not that way sexy
Phil fans are so disturbed it's actually
very sweet song I think diehard
nerdfighters know the course of this
song already John I think that you and I
have finally come to respect the power
of the nerdfighters when we asked them
to find Tiffany with no last name the
first girl who ever dumped you we didn't
realize how seriously they would take
that challenge and when you told them to
find the Corvette in Los Angeles that
had the license plate that said Shazam
they found him we can't underestimate
the power of the nerdfighters and so you
were right to ask them what happens when
someone's brain liquefies because they
knew from a variety of sources I have
discovered that it is most likely that
your brain will come out through your
eyes however your eyes are connected to
your nose through your tear ducts and
your nose is connected to your mouth
which is connected to your stomach so
really your brain will probably come out
of your nose and your mouth and some of
it would drip into your stomach there's
also a chance that it would come out of
your ears there but it's a less of a
chance because you would have to break
hear your drum
some people were suggesting that because
the ancient Egyptians took the Pharaohs
brains out through their noses that that
would be where it came out but there is
a bone there
they have to break to get the brains out
of the nose you just let me know if I'm
making you uncomfortable but at the base
of your eye sockets there's a bone but
there's also a way to get around your
bone and a liquid would have no problems
slipping through that little hole and
now you know it's just one more example
of the awesome power of nerdfighters
John I think that we need to put this
power to the test next week I want to
announce a final project for Brotherhood
to point out that project is going to be
the ultimate test of Awesome we are
going to need the combined efforts of
every single nerdfighter we're going to
ask you to do some things and if you do
it we will make the awesomest thing
happen ever I can't wait to tell you all
about this but I can't do it right now
so for now I'm just gonna say goodbye
everyone and John I'll see you tomorrow
until you figure out what John's is
about but you're not getting any hints
for me and Johnson answering his phone
so I actually have no idea how to solve
that clue
best of luck figuring it out I'm trying
as well so we'll work together right